القنبله المثاليه سباق تسلح جديد بين
اوكرانيا وروسيا باستخدام الطائرات من دون
طيار في التفاصيل القنبله المثاليه سلاح
شديد يصنعه الجنود الاوكرانيين يدويا
لاسقاطها من الطائرات من دون طيار لتدمير
الدبابات الروسيه وفق طبعا تقرير لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه ولكن كيف يتم
تصنيع هذه القنبله تعمل فرق من الجنود
الاوكرانيين في ورشه عمل صغيره في شرقي
اوكرانيا على صنع قنبله يدويه وزنها خفيف
جدا ويمكن اسقاطها من طائره من دون طيار
وتدمير دبابه روسيه تزن نحو 40 طنطا
القنبله المثاليه يجب ان تزن نحو صفر فاصل
49 كيلوغرام وهو اقصى وزن يمكن ان تحمله
الطائره من دون طيار من طراز كمافيكس 3
شرح جندي هنا اوكراني مسؤول عن طريق
الطائرات من دون طيار
حيث الامريكيه هذه التفاصيل تتضمن طبعا
المهمه تعتبر صعبه جدا ودقيقه تجربه قنابل
يدويه ذات تصميمات مختلفه والعمل حول
اليات التفجير لضبطها وهو العمل وهذا ايضا
العمل هو جزء من سباق تسلح اوكراني اوسع
للطائرات من دون طيار مع روسيا كما ايضا
تابعنا التجارب على القنبله المثاليه
اثبتت حتى الساعه نجاحها بعد استخدامها
على الطائره من دون طيار او ما يعرف
بمافيكس 3 الصينيه الصنع بسبب صغر حجمها
وعمر بطاريتها المناسبه في المقابل
مشاهدينا يحاول الجيش الروسي ايضا مثل
الجيش الاكراني جعل الياته الصغيره غير
الماهوله اكثر فتكا حيث تستخدم روسيا
طائرات من دون طياره العسكريه الروسيه
الاكبر حجما مثل طائره شاهد 100 و36 ذاتيه
التفجير والتي تصنع اراد وتطلق بشكل متكرر
لتدمير البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
[موسيقى]